the roots of war lie buried deep in the
human past
it has been a part of us since before
recorded history at the dawn of
civilization our ties to the land drove
us to protect what was ours
we began to raise our children as
hunters and farmers but as soldiers
fear drove us to fight to survive this
primal fear fuel engines of war armies
multiply our empires prove vast
a war is not only fought with soldiers
it is spot within vegetable the spear bo
iron gunpowder Bob wolf pushes the
envelope of Technology granting us
godlike powers
tribal raids have given way to nuclear
missiles smart box and cyber war our
instrument of death becomes so powerful
they now threaten to erase humankind
completely but in there more to war than
meets the eye is it more than just a
plague on humanity war has transformed
our culture and rewritten the map of the
modern world technologies have
revolutionized medicine transportation
communication changed how we live and
how we think this is the story of how
war makes us who we are
how it shapes not just our world our
destiny as a species this is origin
[Music]